the brushstrokes of a great talent
we're in lay on livin trout's düsseldorf
studio which happens to be in his
parents cellar this is where he creates
his much sought-after paintings when
Connie Sutton is mr. Koontz decide to be
an artist either you're born one or
you're not you got to feel a connection
to art for me it became a kind of
addiction kavadi an addiction that
produces colorful abstract expressive
and even wild pictures art critics have
compared Levante cloud style to
Picasso's but he doesn't like the
comparison Murph and Hart began painting
canvases at the tender age of seven at
15 he first began showcasing his work
most of his paintings have English
titles like evening with friends or
yellow mask or faces a motif he finds
particularly fascinating pretty soon I
became fascinated by faces and began
observing other people's facial
expressions
I often sent by the Rhine River watching
people sketching them and observing
their gestures and facial expressions
and then painting them on canvas his
works seemed to strike a chord
his latest exhibitions in Hamburg and
Basel sold out within minutes at all
over the globe from Singapore to London
and Munich galleries at courting the
young German painter but some art
critics believe love and hard work is
just a flash in the pan some tell me
it's a hype make the most of it okay
they can think that and hey maybe
they're right who knows but I am
pursuing my passion I'm not doing this
for the fame or for the money forget
obsessed ease
and yet loving hearts paintings come
with a four or five figure price tag
celebrities like Samuel haba from the
Finnish rock band sunrise Avenue are
among his customers all this attention
and success could easily derail a young
artist like Irvin tart so he tries to
spend a lot of time with friends that
have no connection to the art world as I
skip perfidy and my friends really like
what I'm doing
others no longer want to talk to me or
know me to be frank I think they're just
jealous or can't deal with the situation
somehow distinct mine either sent desert
what's your niche flower calm nights
many laughs I got to know him when he
was just starting out with his art and I
witnessed his career take off but I
don't feel that he's changed as a person
in July 11th route finished high school
incidentally his report card says he got
a C in art he applied to Dusseldorf
prestigious Art Academy where Jersey
Boys and andreas gursky once studied
unfortunately I didn't get into
Dusseldorf's Art Academy but no problem
Basel it was rejected seven times and
today his works are among the most
sought-after and expensive in the world
and there are other art academies in
London New York and elsewhere where I'll
apply clearly this teenager isn't
lacking in confidence currently his
artwork is on show in New York he'd like
the whole world to become exposed to his
art and so far Leon Levine trout has
managed to do a good job in that
department and diligently continues to
work on his paintings
you